how do you know if a director is the
real deal
he had directors are
directors are kind of the the biggest
wild card
uh on a set in terms of well
it's close between actors and directors
but
a director dictates so much of how a job
goes for me
um it's a and it's a big part of why i
will say yes or no to a job
for sure is the director
oh boy
well i think going back to something we
talked about earlier is
i need to feel engaged
and creatively engaged and
if i'm not it might not be the right job
for me
um and the director is usually
who dictates that and because and
sometimes that's because they want
a ton of control sometimes it's because
they don't know what they want at all
or maybe their aesthetic is very
different from mine
so i don't know that i'd think of it as
like
a good or a bad director it's more
about like a match it's i mean it's
almost like a
romantic partnership you know it doesn't
mean
if you if you are dating somebody it
doesn't mean
it's that they are good or bad it's just
how well do you
mesh with them how are your how does
your communication work
what is your taste what are you trying
to get
to when you're working on something so i
it really does feel like a romantic
partnership in a way because it's
it's pretty intimate and you are relying
on each other and you're going to be
around each other in
very stressful situations when you're
tired you're hungry
you know things aren't working out how
do you react how do they react
and can you and i've been very fortunate
i've
i get along with most of the directors i
work with
but i absolutely have had directors that
i can tell
like aren't very fond of because there's
you know my own joy and happiness
and sometimes the project itself that
can only
bring so much joy or happiness but
the the there are directors that like
i'm like oh this just isn't
isn't going great like it's just not
working out and i and
i do think my job is to serve them for
the most part
and so i try to do my best but it
doesn't always work
but it yeah it's it's i don't know
there's a weird
chemistry you try to gauge up front as
best you can
will this be a good match but you know
until you're in the trenches with
somebody you don't know how
it'll be what's the mark of a
professional
a professional director that maybe a
newer director someone a little more
green
won't have as many traits or practices
habits
yeah you know directing such an
interesting one
there's a there's a joke that you'll
hear sometimes on set
like who who has the least amount of
experience on a set
and almost always it's the director
it's it's just the nature of getting to
a directing position
can be very that you know sometimes it's
who you know
sometimes you wrote a script and you're
being you know
who knows and
i think one of the things that's that
has to be the most challenging for a new
director or an inexperienced
director is there's this big machine
moving
and at this point for somebody like me
like i have a lot more to learn
but i've been doing it for a long time
and so
when we're looking at a scene and an
actor's like oh i
actually i don't want to sit here i want
to get up and i want to go by the
stand by the window is for
some directors that might freak them out
completely
um they because they they don't know
they've made a plan
and then as soon as something breaks in
the plan be that an actor's decision
or maybe bad weather or a location falls
through or there's an equipment
malfunction
is the ability to change
and still you know whatever that
intention of the scene is
is that you can still find it but using
none of what you planned
and i think for a newer director that's
got to be
so hard is finding you know for me
one of the things i'm good at is uh i
think
i'm good at at least is sequencing like
in a scene it's like okay
well we don't need this close-up because
we're gonna come around and when
when she walks through here this shot
will land so we'll have that line
dialogue here and then we need to be cam
shooting or like i can very quickly
piece together like okay this is all the
okay yeah we'll have all the pieces and
a lot of directors can't do that
they they just just simply by because of
you know not being not having
shot as much so it doesn't mean
necessarily good or bad
but that ability to think on your feet i
think is one of the most
valuable things especially for tv
because it's so fast paced or lower
budget
feature you you just can't stop you have
to go go go
and i think that's probably
that's probably one of the biggest
things and and i don't know i don't know
how to like advise
a director exactly because some of it is
just hours just putting in
just doing it doing it more and
learning so you know so i guess going
back to similar to
my job or an actor's job is preparation
is knowing that they know
what a scene or a whole piece needs to
feel like or be like
and then the ability to improvise i
guess if you're too rigid
and then something falls apart will you
be able to adjust i guess that's
and maybe not and maybe you know there
are directors like david fincher
who are just like he is going to get
what he wants the way he wants it
you know so it's not like being precise
is
wrong it's just on the shows i've been
on
you can't like you can't get everything
perfectly and so how do you
still make it work yeah
generally speaking what's an appropriate
amount of time a director should give a
cinematographer
to light a scene uh
you know in terms of time to light a
scene
there's definitely no answer because so
like no no strict answer because it all
depends on
the size of a shoot um and
maybe the better way to think about it
is how much time
do you need do they do the actors need
because you the more time
i take to light the less time actors
have to act
the fewer takes a director gets to
direct
so that's all part of the factor and
then also
how many scenes you have that day you
know if you're in one location for the
day
and it's one time of day
one mood then i can take a lot more time
at the beginning of the day because
we're never moving but if we have to do
three location moves that day
we need to we need to start shooting as
soon as possible
so it's kind of a big math problem
because i could light a scene
for two years like there's no such thing
as like
okay i'm done now it's perfect i could
go forever
and so the things that caused me to be
like all right it's good enough or
whatever is what else is in play
and and you know there's an a.d
somewhere nearby that
is like hey are you done like there's
somebody
generally around but it really depends
on the scale
because you know if you you can
light a scene with no lights if you do
the right time of day in the right
location
that's it you just if you plan it out
you're like if we are here
at 7 30 and the camera's ready to go
we need to shoot at 7 30 because by 8 30
the light's no good anymore and then we
have to come in and supplement it and
that'll take a whole hour
or whatever so so every scene is a
little different
um you definitely fall into rhythms uh
you know last show i shot
the beginning of the day is always
slower because people are unloading
equipment and all that
but we would block through a scene and
then
you know i talk to the director and the
a.d
and i i'll we'll kind of run through
okay we need
seven shots for this scene and i'll be
like okay well this side
i need 40 minutes let's say
to light this but then we have a turn
around
and i need to reset the light for that
and so that means that's going to be
another maybe
20 minutes and so it's every scene
every day every location every shot is
kind of its own animal honestly so
it's you have to be constantly thinking
about
that but it's yeah it just varies
anywhere from zero minutes to you know
a day of lighting truthfully like it
could it can really be anywhere
in between have you been on set where
it's been
you know six hours worth of lighting one
shot
well so there are scenes if there is a
scene
uh where for instance
like a long one or like a steady cam
that goes through a restaurant we did
that on my last show there's a steadicam
shot that starts in a parking lot
it comes into a restaurant goes in
through the kitchen
back out through the rest of the
restaurant into another room
where then there's a whole family
waiting for them so
i don't so what we did is we basically
lit the whole restaurant
and the outdoor parking lot and that
took i mean
i don't remember but it's probably half
a day
but then it meant that we were mostly
lit so not only did we do that steadicam
shot but then you jump into doing your
dialogue scenes
and the light you kind of you sort of
light 360.
and so in theory you can point any
direction
and you can shoot now ideally you are
able to tweak this and that
but um yeah for if you if you can
capture
a lot of material or light a whole space
that's something i try to do
when i can is lighting a space a little
more because then it allows you like
okay we've gotten these shots but now
we bump in here we don't need to tweak
the light oh we turn here we don't need
to tweak the light
now that's hard and it's hard to make
look
good but that is
that is one way of approaching it so a
lot more time
up front but then you just crank
you